mouth cream cheese leave it at the
fridge for 5 or 10 minutes they're nice
and soft trust me
your arms will be thanking you sugar in
this cheesecake is New York cheesecake
because of baked says no base start
creaming the cheese and the sugar
spending the amount of time I do in the
States
if there's one thing they know how to do
out there is the most amazing impressive
cheesecake rich delicious but so simple
work the bowl lift the bowl to your
advantage
really whisk whisk whisk whisk lovely
ice and creamy now your eggs add the
extra mixture bit by bit do it this way
it's more efficient Hey you're
incorporating a lot of air B the mixture
doesn't separate last though your egg
lovely of course you can use electric
mixer but why go to the gym we can just
make a cheesecake add a cheesecake add a
keep the finger wings away now couple of
tablespoons of flour give it a whisk
stop some your lumpy now I want to send
that cheesecake
over the freshness zest the lemon in
there I want to sort of tart it up even
more fold in some fresh raspberries so
just mix them through be careful to
crush them then grease the cake tin with
butter this will ensure your cheesecake
slides out beautifully can you mix let
that fall in now take your cake tin and
just tap it mixture hits the bottom of
the Katyn the raspberries rise and
you've got raspberries at the top the
middle in the bottom and also stops all
these little pockets of air trapping
underneath the mixture from the cake tin
there's no holes in the cheesecake now
into the oven 180 degrees for 35 to 40
minutes
mm slightly souffle DUP pull off that's
the color I wanted on top and look at it
it's one of the simplest yet the most
stylish cheesecakes anywhere
peaceful take your figs and sort of
place them in gently lovely
traditionally we always put jam in there
but chocolate and donuts Wow to die for
add the cream